a high school valedictorian in Petaluma
California says administrators censored
part of her graduation speech
seventeen-year-old Lulabelle site says
her mic was turned off when she spoke
about the school's handling of alleged
sexual assault other students say it was
not the right time or place to bring up
the issue
Matea via al spoke to the team but it is
always difficult saying goodbye
lulubelle site says she wanted to use
her graduation address at Petaluma high
school to remind her classmates of the
obstacles they've overcome but we are
not too young to speak up but when she
veered off her approved speech to bring
up the issue of sexual assault on campus
valedictorians my quit silent even when
some people on this campus those same
people my first immediate thought was
just stand your ground sites ended up
returning to her seat later posting her
full speech online including the part
that was cut off the class of 2018 has
demonstrated time and time again that we
may be a new generation but we are not
too young to speak up site says she
filed a police report after she was
sexually assaulted on campus last fall
but says she doesn't feel the school did
enough to protect her after the alleged
attack I was like there's got to be
something I can do to make this change
because if I could prevent this from
happening tomorrow girls then that would
be good enough for me but she says she
was warned multiple times her mic would
be turned off if she deviated from the
pre-approved speech in a statement the
school district's assistant
superintendent said due to student
privacy issues we cannot and should not
respond with specific information we can
say that when issues of sexual assault
come to our attention local law
enforcement has initial jurisdiction and
determines the course of action the
Petaluma Police Department has not
responded to our questions some of her
fellow students say the graduation
ceremony wasn't the appropriate venue to
raise the issue we're all celebrating us
leaving you know it's
she was kind of taking it off and I'm
like what happened to her there are some
students that will say this was way too
serious then what is the timer replaces
my response to that for CBS this morning
midday of young Los Angeles
we should note that Petaluma high school
says sexual assault claims are reported
to the police and the school follows up
on a case-by-case basis according to
state education codes but she's the
valedictorian yes seems like there
should be some way to address the issue
yeah there's no such thing as a good
time but I think that it's important for
her to speak out I could see why people
might have been turned off enough I
admire the fact that she stood up and
spoke out well did you wait say there
could be a better way to handle this
some sort of compromise while addressing
because abuse fosters in silence exactly
right